há dois anos a gente fez uma viagem para
um país que quase ninguém visita à
bielorrússia
a gente chegou num trem daqueles antigos
vindas ea gente cruzou a fronteira da
polônia pela tabela rússia fronteira de
terra ea gente está muito apreensivo
porque a gente não sabia se ia conseguir
entrar no país
a bielo rússia tinha acabado de abolir o
visto para brasileiros fazer pouco tempo
será que os agentes de imigração
saberiam disso lá fomos nós pra fila e
quando o policial chamou eu falei com a
voz trêmula e ele me respondeu aquela
cara fechada e quem for exatamente ele
cantou a música do hit dos anos 80
foi surreal naquela hora o medo acabou
a gente caiu na gargalhada e conseguiu
entrar no país sem problemas
a rússia não faz parte do roteiro
turístico da maioria das pessoas quando
a gente pensa em viajar de férias
tipicamente a gente pensa em lugares um
pouco mais conhecidos como nova york
paris
a disney mas não a bielo rússia mas
quando a gente tem um pouquinho mais de
tempo passa a fazer sentido e os lugares
diferentes
no nosso caso o último dia 17 de março a
gente completou 13 mil dias de viagem
a gente saiu em 2010 de niterói com o
objetivo inicial de morar em buenos
aires mas chegando lá a gente percebeu
que a gente podia continuar em movimento
ea gente passou então a ficar viajando
de forma permanente e assim a gente se
tornou o casal partiu primeiro casal de
nome digitais do brasil
desde então a gente passou por pouco
mais de 300 cidades ao redor de 67
países
e normalmente em cada país que a gente
visita a gente passa pelo menos um mês
nesse caso à parte
estou por exemplo a gente tinha acabado
de passar uma temporada de três meses na
polônia e aí a gente chegou na
bielo-rússia onde a gente passou também
três meses
em seguida a gente foi programa agente
também passou três meses e por aí foi
todo país tem uma fama e acontece o
mesmo com a bielo rússia tem muita
propaganda negativa sobre o país mas a
gente não liga não porque a estrada
mostrou pra gente que existem dois
mundos o mundo real eo mundo dos jornais
o mundo real é sempre muito mais
divertido na mão do nosso primeiro dia
da minha luz ea gente foi ao
supermercado fazer umas comprinhas
e olha só que a gente encontrou no
supermercado
vocês já viram alguém vestido assim no
supermercado do seu bairro
nem eu e quando a gente saiu do
supermercado outra surpresa do outro
lado da rua havia um rio mas não viu
qualquer era will completamente
congelado
eu nem sabia que rios podiam ficar
congelados
aquela imensidão de água completamente
congelada e o mais interessante é que
pessoas andavam sobre ele tranquilamente
havia até pessoas com bicicleta e um
pescador ali no meio daquela imensidão
pescando eu tomei coragem e resolvi
também arriscar mas vocês podem perceber
que estou perto da borda eu acho que só
um pouquinho pra tirar foto
a nossa experiência a denúncia foi ótima
a gente passou o inverno lá eu pude
experimentar o que é viver inter atrás
glaciais
agora dá para entender por que as
meninas tivessem assim pode falar que
estou linda eu tô parecendo uma poodle
[Risadas]
todo mundo adora viajar na verdade que
viajar pra gente a possibilidade de ver
essas coisas diferentes e experimentar
novas possibilidades
acontece que toda vez que a gente sai de
viagem é muito caro né não
eu lembro da primeira vez que viajei
para o exterior eu passei 30 dias na
europa quando eu voltei ao perceber que
tinha conseguido a façanha de gastar
absolutamente todo dinheiro que eu já
tinha acumulado na vida
até aquele momento e estourar o cheque
especial e por que não o cartão de
crédito também se 30 dias de viagem
fazem esse estrago nas nossas contas
imagina o que três mil dias de viagem
não pode fazer
a sorte é que antes de a gente começar
essa jornada eu tinha uma idéia
brilhante eu joguei na loteria tena que
eu não ganhei então tive que eu tive que
buscar uma outra forma de viabilizar
esse projeto eo que aconteceu foi que
felizmente a gente descobriu que você
não precisa ser rico para viver viajando
pelo mundo razão pela qual sai muito
caro quando você sai de viagem têm a ver
com três elementos fundamentais
o primeiro é que quando você sai de
viagem você já tem as contas fixas da
sua casa e você enquanto está fora
mesmo não estando mais em casa você
continua a pagar por essas contas fixas
e além delas você também paga pelas
contas da viagem
e aí fica pesado mesmo né mas além disso
como você só tem 30 dias de férias
você tem que scola escolher lugares com
muita certeza então você escolhe os
lugares mais badalados que por acaso são
os lugares mais caros não bastando isso
você vai na alta temporada que é o
período mais caro mas quando você passa
o tempo todo viajando sem precisar fazer
nada disso e é o nosso caso e é por essa
razão que a gente nos últimos oito anos
surpreendente mente sempre gastou muito
menos viajando pelo mundo porque a gente
gastava para ficar parado aqui no brasil
para viabilizar essa vida a gente
decidiu parar de pagar as contas fixas
de casa
quando a gente fez isso a gente percebeu
que a gente podia investir o dinheiro
que a gente usava para pagar as contas
fixas na nossa viagem
a gente decidiu então deixar de ter uma
casa
mas como todo mundo a gente também
precisa de um teto
sabe aquelas pessoas que viajam de modo
home e viajam pelo mundo levam à casa
sobre rodas
eles podem ir para onde eles quiserem
legal né essa foi exatamente a solução
que a gente não adotou eu vou conversar
a pensar uma coisa pra vocês eu adoro um
a caminha confortável um banho quentinho
uma cozinha bem equipada e banda larga
o senhor como eu amo banda larga
internet rápida
eu admiro demais quem vive em moto home
mas não é pra gente a gente gosta mesmo
é de usar a casa dos outros
principalmente quando elas são boas
olha aí em porto em portugal
olha aí na bulgária olha aí na pelúcia e
olha essa vista na nossa casa da croácia
ao longo dos últimos oito anos a gente
alugou apartamentos por temporada em
todos os lugares pra gente passou ao
redor do mundo e para fazer isso a gente
usou aplicativos específicos que são
úteis para esse propósito é interessante
desses aplicativos aqueles torna o
processo muito simples e sem nenhuma
burocracia
a gente escolhe os apartamentos que a
gente quer a gente paga com cartão de
crédito e no dia combinado a gente
simplesmente chega lá encontra o
apartamento todo prontinho limpinho pra
gente simplesmente chegar e morar com
total conforto e com tudo que a gente
precisa para poder trabalhar
esses apartamentos eles já são
completamente equipados
a gente não precisa trazer praticamente
nada obviamente eles têm internet rápida
eles têm tudo que você possa precisar de
cozinha eles têm roupa de cama eles
tento área e eles têm máquina de lavar
roupa e isso é bem importante porque é
isso que permite que a gente viaje com
muito pouco isso aqui é exatamente o que
a gente leva com a gente ao redor do
mundo cada um de nós tem uma marinha que
ela começa e uma mochila como essa aqui
a gente carrega a roupa pra dez dias e
os nossos equipamentos de trabalho e é
tudo o que a gente precisa porque esse
apartamento já tem absolutamente tudo a
gente não precisa de mais nada e o mais
interessante é que como a gente passa
pelo menos um mês em cada lugar
a gente tem ainda a possibilidade de
negociar o valor desses apartamentos ea
gente consegue ótimos descontos com isso
a abbott falou da bielo-rússia e lá me
se a gente alugou um apartamento no qual
a gente pagou 400 euros por mês
de negociar isso para todas as contas do
apartamento
hoje em dia isso equivale a
aproximadamente dois mil reais
não é sempre que a gente consegue
exatamente um valor como s
mas é um valor bastante razoável ea
gente sempre consegue ficar dentro do
nosso orçamento
quando a gente saiu para cinema digital
a gente combinou entre gente que a gente
já tem um orçamento mensal que não
poderia nunca passar de 6 mil reais por
mês
todas as contas da gente tinha que caber
16 mil reais por mês portanto hospedagem
passagem seguro de saúde internacional
restaurante passeio supermercado tudo
tinha que dar nesse valor
para alguns isso pode parecer muitos pra
outros pode parecer pouco mas fato é que
são 13 mil pessoas 3 mil reais para cada
um de nós mas só os profissionais já de
longa data a gente consegue ganhar bem
em três mil reais é o valor equivale a
três salários mínimos
é um valor bastante razoável não é
nenhum absurdo quando a gente fala numa
digital
o que mais salta aos olhos é a parte da
viagem é a parte da competição mas se
você parar pra pensar
o mais importante mesmo é o trabalho é
ele que paga as contas e permite que a
gente viva mas desse jeito não vamos
falar um pouquinho aqui de trabalho em
2010 vive ele já trabalhava de casa 100%
do tempo e online
ele vivia de um software que ele tinha
construído dois anos antes tinha e
cobrava uma assinatura para
empreendedores de toda parte do brasil
eu era fotógrafo de casamento e eu
precisei fazer uns ajustes para que
viabilizassem os primeiros anos da nossa
vida nova de então a gente resolveu nos
primeiros anos voltar ao brasil para uma
visitinha rápida de três meses onde
fazia uma série de casamentos dos nove
meses seguintes
eu tratava foto montados alguns
empregados aulas para trás noivas e
deixava novos negócios
bom a questão do trabalho ela é
importante não é importante só pela
questão do dinheiro pra falar a verdade
o trabalho é importante para uma outra
razão muito mais profunda
se você parar para pensar o que traz
realmente felicidade pra gente mas eu
digo felicidade duradoura aquela que
todo dia faz você acordar sabe motivado
para fazer alguma coisa eu digo pra
vocês o que mais pode trazer felicidade
da nossa vida é a gente ter um objetivo
difícil de alcançar e a gente buscar
constantemente se desafiar para alcançar
seus objetivos em outras palavras o que
traz felicidade
a gente tem um trabalho concreto
significativo um trabalho com o
propósito forte que faz a gente querer
levantar da cama e realizar alguma coisa
todo dia quando a gente tem isso a gente
consegue ter uma felicidade muito
duradoura
a verdade é que se fosse só viajar e
passar oito anos viajando com toda a
sinceridade não seria viável não seria
sustentável porque viajar é muito legal
mas sinceramente a gente precisa também
trabalhar ser produtivo se sentir útil
fazer alguma coisa a mais e sentir que
está crescendo sente que está se
desenvolvendo isso é essencial e é por
isso que o trabalho é a parte mais
importante dessa vida nômade é ele que
de fato torna possível que a gente passa
a vida viajando
dessa forma muito mais do que apenas
pela questão do dia mas só trabalhar
também não dá vamos combinar é porque se
a gente só trabalhar a vida acaba meio
que virando um tédio porque a vida ela
precisa também de um pouco de aventura
ela precisa de coisas diferentes ela
precisa de coisas que saiam da ordem pra
poder a gente se sentir desafiado o mais
legal nessa vida nômade é que ela
equilibra muito bem essas duas coisas a
gente tem um trabalho que é constante
que está sempre ali aquela rotina forte
mas o nosso ambiente à nossa volta ele
está sempre mudando
eu lembro por exemplo o primeiro dia que
a gente chegou a morar em istambul e ea
gente deixou as coisas no apartamento em
seguida a gente foi um sapato e quando a
gente chegou no restaurante a gente
abrir o cardápio e não fazia a menor
idéia do que estava escrito lá e aí o
que a gente faz numa hora dessa gente
chame o garçom e pergunta pra ele você
fala inglês e é óbvio que ele responde
que não e aí você olha para o outro se
fala o que a gente faz
o cardápio tinha algumas fotos a gente
não tinha a menor idéia do que era
aquele prato só vamos experimentar então
e ver no que dá
torce aí cada um toque pede um diferente
porque vai que um pelo menos dá certo né
e aí veio o prato felizmente deu tudo
certo mas o que eu tô tentando ilustrar
que o nosso trabalho é constante mas a
cada dia da nossa vida acontece uma
coisa meio diferente assim que a gente
não sabe como lidar com ela ainda porque
uma pequena aventura que a gente
introduziu e nesse mesmo dia quando a
gente sai para fazer as compras para
casa a gente se depara com algo que a
gente tem a menor idéia do que são essas
coisas
é claro que depois de dois meses morando
em istambul a gente já com esse cardápio
de trás pra frente a gente já sabia o
nome de todos os pratos a gente sabia já
tinha experimentado a maior parte dessas
coisas aqui imagina quanta gente
aprendeu nesse período é sensacional
viver dessa forma porque viver como numa
digital traz muita variedade para a
nossa vida
eu acho na verdade a gente acha que
seria muito legal se mais pessoas
pudessem viver dessa forma também é por
essa razão que a gente é um tempo atrás
começou um projeto em que a gente tem
uma meta um pouco usada
mas talvez vocês possam ajudar a gente
nessa meta
a gente deseja até 2025 colaborar
diretamente para um milhão de pessoas se
tornarem numa digitais
eu sei que parece um pouquinho ousado
então vejam seja a coisa mais fácil do
mundo de se fazer mas não é impossível
algumas iniciativas para isso a gente já
começou
seria muito legal se num futuro breve
alguns de vocês participassem desse
projeto com a gente e fizessem parte
desse milhão
e aí partiu galera